es geht los jetzt wird der weltraum müll
weggeräumt mit hilfe von vier greifarmen
sollen trümmerteile im all eingefangen
werden um dann in der erdatmosphäre zu
verglühen so der plan der europäischen
weltraumagentur esa die jetzt mit ihrer
mission klier space man eine weltweite
premiere startet und das soll erst der
anfang sein
die esa fordert quasi ein weltweites
gesetz zur weltraumschrott kriegs um
science-fiction hier gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen die aktuelle bedrohungslage
ist groß ist droht wirklich eine riesige
katastrophe 60 jahre raumfahrt haben
ihre spuren hinterlassen trümmerteile
ausgebrannte raketenteile oder defekte
satelliten beispielsweise es gibt
schätzungen nach denen mehr als 20.000
objekte mit einem durchmesser von
mindestens zehn zentimetern um unseren
planeten kreisen und zwar unkontrolliert
750.000 kleinere müll teilchen die etwa
einen zentimeter groß sind und von der
erde aus nicht zu erkennen sind kommen
außerdem noch dazu insgesamt sind wohl
2700 tonnen weltraumschrott mit extrem
hoher geschwindigkeit unterwegs eine
riesige bedrohung für die etwa 2000
aktiven satelliten die wir derzeit im
weltraum haben treffen diese schrott
teilchen beispielsweise auf satelliten
module kommt es zur korrosion die
vorzeitige alterung der getroffenen
module ist nicht mehr aufzuhalten doch
das ist noch nicht einmal der worst case
denn selbst schrott teilchen von einem
zentimeter größe können satelliten auch
auf einen schlag komplett zerstört und
das hat direkte folgen für unser leben
auf der erde denn wir alle brauchen
funktionierende satelliten um zu
telefonieren fernsehen zu sehen oder uns
vom navi von anna b lotsen zu lassen
internet und so weiter und so fort und
es droht noch eine schlimmere
katastrophe dass kessler syndrom die
zerstörung aller satelliten in einer
kettenreaktion schon heute schauen wir
diesen effekt quasi in zeitlupe zu immer
wieder werden satelliten zerstört es
entstehen noch mehr schrott teilchen die
dann wieder andere satelliten zerstören
und so weiter und so fort irgendwann
kann sich dieser prozess aber dramatisch
beschleunigen und dann innerhalb von
tagen oder stunden alle satelliten
weltweit zerstören eine absolute
katastrophe
eine wirklich bedrohliche lage die sich
in zukunft noch verschärfen wird denn
allein elenas plant 42.000 satelliten
ins all zu schießen
zudem sind auch militärprojekte von
verschiedenen staaten mal angedacht dazu
esa chef jan wörner
stellen sie sich vor wie gefährlich das
segeln auf hoher see wäre wenn alle
schiffe die in der geschichte jemals
verloren gegangen sind immer noch auf
dem wasser treiben würden das ist die
aktuelle situation im orbit und es darf
so nicht weitergehen und deswegen plant
die europäische weltraumagentur esa
jetzt eine weltweite premiere bereits in
sechs jahren 2025 soll placebase one
staaten und erste vorbereitungen werden
jetzt schon im märz 2020 beginnen 120
millionen euro soll das ganze kosten und
der plan ist nicht ohne
dazu wird ein raumfahrzeug in den orbit
gebracht dass zunächst ein raketen teil
mit einer masse von etwa 100 kilogramm
ansteuert konkret handelt es sich um die
oberstufe fest bei der trägerrakete vega
dieses raketen teil kreis seit 2013 auf
einer umlaufbahn zwischen 660 und 800
kilometern höhe um die erde das
raumfahrzeug soll es dann mit hilfe von
vier greifarmen einfangen beide steuern
dann tiefer hinunter in die
erdatmosphäre wo sie dann restlos
verglühen und zwar ohne schaden
anzurichten fest steht für vega
secondary payload adapter und eignet
sich den esa angaben zufolge gut als
erstes ziel
denn zum einen hat dieses raketenteile
eine relativ einfache form und ist zudem
sehr robust die esa hat das schweizer
startup klier space mit dieser mission
beauftragen langfristig sind dann auch
missionen geplant die deutlich
anspruchsvoller sind und mehrere objekte
gleichzeitig einfangen und für einen die
orbiting sorgen sollen laut der
weltraumagentur könnten sich solche
reinigungsprodukte als zukunftsmarkt
herausstellen auch wenn es derzeit noch
keine konkreten gesetze gibt die dazu
verpflichten den verursachten
weltraumschrott wieder zu entsorgen doch
jan wörner schwebt genau so etwas vor
erfordert dass alle die demnächst einen
satelliten ins all schießen wollen einen
vertrag abschließen müssen darin sollte
festgehalten werden wer die beseitigung
bezahlt und welches unternehmen den
weltraumschrott bei bedarf wieder
zurückholt orbitale schrottplatz
anklicken anschauen und hyperraum tv
abonnieren neu bei unserem wissenschafts
netzwerk essent 1054 und
absolut mega kanal bis dann bleibt dran
also an klicken hier